Let's return to our example earlier of me owing
you money, and let's say it so happens that
the mutual clock drift is 5 between you and
me. So my clock, when it reads 3:00 PM,
your clock reads 8:00 PM, so that is the
mutual clock drift that we have. And let's say
that the interprocess communication time, the lower bound on
that is 2. So what happens is that, as I
told you earlier, I am telling you any time
after 5:00 PM. You can get the money from
me, from my bank. And so you instructed your
bank, to debit at 8:00 PM. But unfortunately, your
8:00 PM, is my 3:00 PM, because, our mutual
clock drift is 5. So when your request went
out, it took 2 units of time to get
to the server. Went out and the Central Bank got
your message asking for a debit transaction, but the
credit is not there yet, because I'm waiting till
5:00 PM to actually send my credit advice to
the bank. And therefore your request which came in at
4:00 PM, because you sent it relative to me,
you are five hours ahead, and in terms of
real time, you're actually six hours ahead, and so
the message is received at 4:00 PM, and your request
is declined. And this is coming about, because
of the fact that your interprocess communication time
Mew is less than the mutual clock drift
that we're seeing between these two clocks which
is five. On the other hand, if the
mutual clock drift is less than the inter-process
communication times, in this case, let's say that
the clocks are more well behaved. Epsilon is
one, meaning the mutual clock drift between you
and me is just one. And so, exactly the
same scenario. When it is 3:00 PM, in my
branch, your branch is saying your time is 4:00
PM. Of course, you've given the advice to your branch to debit at 8:00 PM. So at
my local time, 5:00 PM, I send a credit
advice. Received by the bank, and at your time,
8:00 PM, which is not quite in sync with
real time, and is also drifting with respect to my
time, but the bound is less than the lower
bound on the interprocess communication time. And therefore when you
send your debit request at 8:00 PM, your local
time, which actually in real time 6:00 PM, it's perfectly
fine because when it is received in the Central Bank,
the real time is 8:00 PM. And it is received
later than the current request, and so your
request is honored, you're happy and you can
go home. So the important takeaway is that
in constructing distributed applications which depend on real
time, it is important to make sure that,
that are bounds on individual clock drift. As
well as mutual clock drift. So individual clock
drift is what my, my clock is reading at
any point of time and how far off is
it, from real time. So that is individual clock
drift and you want that to be bound by
some small value, which we call k. And the other
important thing is that you want to make sure
that the mutual clock drift is very very small also.
So that there is no anomaly when the interactions
like what we showed here and the whole thing hinges
on the relationship between mutual clock
drift, the individual clock drift k, and
the interprocess communication time. Informally, so long
as you make sure that the interprocess
communication time is significantly higher than the
clock drifts, whether it is mutual or
individual clock drift, you can ensure that
there are no anomalies in the system.